all right crystal
crystal where'd you grow up where are
you from originally um upper derby
and tell me about your family growing up
you had mom and dad um i was raised for
my grandparents my grandfather and
my step-grandmother
but she raised me so she was like i
called her mom what happened to your
biological mom
she um
she had an addiction problem too she
went to go get milk left me with a
friend i guess formula
and she didn't come back for a couple
days so
how old were you when this happened six
weeks i believe so so that's when you
went to your grandparents yeah
how would you describe your childhood in
general my childhood uh
well i mean i knew i knew they were my
grandparents and i remember the first
time meeting my real mom i was always
afraid however my dad were coming to
steal me
and uh
i mean i i
i didn't want for anything you know what
i mean i had brand new school clothes
when it was that time christmases were
good
but i was
i wasn't my mom and dad you know what i
mean like when everyone else was writing
happy father's day at school i would
write happy father's day
and then he'd say dear dad so i'd write
like the other kids but then i'd go
erase it before i went home papa was
always embarrassed you know i mean they
were older
but your childhood was good with your
grandparents no abuse nothing like that
no no not abuse i mean my grandfather he
was um
a drinker he drank every day but he went
to work like a functional one i guess
um my mom was like my grandmom she drank
on the weekends played poker machine
like that was her thing
um and she had five kids they were all
older they all did drugs
but like it wasn't like i didn't know
that they did drugs at first but then my
one uncle he didn't have no kids so he
was like he talked to me he was like my
dad
and i found him dead
have a drug overdose heroin when i was
nine there was like
five or six i us all the cousins had
slept over that weekend
and uh
he was asleep in the chair and he didn't
wake up
you finished high school
no i got my ged
when did you drop out of i dropped yeah
well my grandfather died my mom got a
check for me survivors benefit or
whatever
so uh she kept me enrolled but i didn't
go so once the truancy fines over came
like more than what the check was then
she signed me out finally
but um i got pregnant early like 17
so i went and got my ged and all and i i
wound up getting it before i would have
got it if i stayed in
but so i got my g day my license
and had my kid
and drugs started for you at what age
uh the first time i smoked weed was
probably like 12 11 or 12.
and then you know drinking and that was
like a weekend thing for my family so
they would the adults would be drinking
and all the kids you know and then
everything was a party someone got
baptized it was a party easter was a
part everything was a party so all the
cousins you know we all would be
sneaking beers and drinking i was one of
the younger ones
you know like if there was four of us i
was the younger out then four
and then three younger underneath me you
know
and you ended up going on your own at
what age i don't know what you went on
your own at what age went out on my own
i still i lived with my mom when i had
my kid with my daughter 18. um i got my
first appointment
my first appointment 23 24.
how old are you now 40 you're 40.
you have how many kids two two girls 17
and 21.
and where are they now um 17 year olds
with my aunt and 21 year old she went
with my uh biological mom she was
staying with the same aunt and then
i think like last year the year before
she got to fight my aunt and went to my
biological mom
you stay in contact with your kids
um
no i i did
and um
and i just said like i've been i've been
like this run because usually i'll get
clean after so many months or i'll go to
jail and get clean when i get down there
um this runs been like five or six years
and
that oldest one don't really she don't
talk to me i don't have her number
and the youngest one if i call like my
aunt where she lives she'll talk to me
and you know
but no i don't really see them and talk
to them that much
and i was real close with them i was
like you know i had a house i had
in-ground pool
i had a job like i had my oldest until
14 and then that's when that's when [ __ ]
start blowing up
for me
your drug use went from alcohol to
harder drugs well alcohol is a teenager
to zannis and coke and all the party
drugs you know acid and all that then
eventually i think like 17 it was the
first time i tried heroin right before i
got pregnant with my daughter my oldest
daughter and when i got pregnant with
her that was it no drugs no cigarettes i
didn't do nothing with both of them i
didn't do any drugs or alcohol
and then um
each time after a couple months you know
i would start getting high again
so today you're using fentanyl or heroin
oh
nothing really has heroin in it now it's
pretty much all fentanyl and tranq i
forget the real name what they call it
but what is trink tranq is animal
tranquilizer
there's a there is a name to it but i
don't know but um
yeah it's fentanyl and tranq trying
pretty much just put you out like you
you're up talking one minute and then
you're sleeping you either wake up sick
you gotta get more but you don't feel
hot like how heroin used to get you on
you know you know
it you don't have that one feeling you
don't get that a furious
you just do it just not to be sick
you don't really get
a feeling you used to get
and it's an animal tranquilizer for
which kind of animal a horse or an
elephant that's what they say fentanyl
and carfentanil and this tranquilizer
you never know you know what's the what
mix it is it really just puts you out
puts you out yeah
and if you get something that don't put
you out you're just not sick there's not
really any
if you work high to it to it
you know like when i first started doing
heroin you'd get like this warm feeling
and you'd be ambitious i'm gonna do this
and then she could still go to work you
could hold a job well in the beginning
this stuff you can't because you've got
to get high every couple hours
you know so it's like you poke and if
you smoke and i smoke crack too poke and
smoke and poke and smoke steal and poke
and smoke and steal
no there's not nothing else there's
nothing else just poke smoke steel
trick if that's your thing
sometimes it is
but there's no other life
at all
you've been saying here i met you at
near kensington and allegheny that was
you've been here how long
two years or two and a half years down
here homeless
tell me about living down here
coming down here
it's um
i guess that it's so unnormal it becomes
your normal you know
but i um i got into meth
with people up in in a different county
in bucks county it's like more of a
money area than where i'm from
and i thought i found like this miracle
drug you don't get sick from it and you
can go to work you know what i mean
these people all had jobs and houses
dressed nice and i thought i found a
miracle drug and i didn't do dope
but i don't know they gave me too much
because what happened but did something
to my brain
so i come down here
and these people like they say [ __ ] and
it's like and i never had schizophrenic
never had no mental problems like that i
come down here and i don't know if it's
because it's so
[ __ ] whacked the [ __ ] that you see
and the things that happen
my brain don't know how to
uh
understand it
i think everything
it's fake it's an act it's not [ __ ]
real
so like if i hear a gunshot when
everyone else is going down
like [ __ ] that is this the actors again
trying to get my shot [ __ ] up [ __ ]
that i don't believe anything's real
around me and
that's how i'm describing it because
if it is real they're it's it's really
crazy
to me you know i was on the bus the
other day and the lady said
anybody [ __ ] with me i got a can of
aerosol vaginal aerosol or something
aerosol can and a lighter
and by the end of the thing she was she
was doing the aerosol can and the
lighter to the dude's face
like is this real is this really real
and people getting in fights because
this guy's mixing up his [ __ ] and this
guy don't want him mixing it up here
and they're pulling guns and i'm not
wasn't raised like that you know i mean
i never even saw a gun
before
and um so it's like unreal to me yeah
it's like a crazy lifestyle does it
become normalized after a while yeah
like now you're used to it and it's just
every day
yeah this is what you see
yeah this and i still i'm not sure what
what is real and what's not real
but sometimes i feel like there's
there's actors out there like maybe i
don't know maybe we're like test
lab tests for the government or
something
and they put like actors there like
weird things happen and these people
will know things that
like they say you never told somebody
you know what i mean and they say it but
they're pretending like they're talking
to someone else but it's something that
you just lived
and i don't do like i try not to do the
meth because of that being able to do
that to my head you know what i mean
but i don't know if they're putting meth
into other drugs not it's like that all
the time everywhere
even if i leave if i don't do the drugs
i try to go to center city and it's like
it's like this everywhere
i try to go to rehab nine times i've
been in 34 regards
and you've been to 34 rehabs
and um
so i don't go to rehab to learn how to
stay away from drugs no more you know
what i mean i know all the little
cliches what i hate you know and [ __ ] i
go to put the distance between me and
the drug and then after that my my brain
gets back to normal and i want to do
good you know what i mean and this time
like i didn't want to for a while
so every once in a while i have like you
know bad enough dates where i'm like
[ __ ] that and then i go and i sit and
it's six hours or eight hours and they
don't get in nowhere so now you're like
[ __ ] it you gotta go back out and
you know
but like
before it went real dope i never lasted
six months i would get that shot that
would give me like your fury of wanting
to do good i don't get that no more
at all and i don't know if it's cause
all the other times i had hope like i'll
get back with my kids and you know i
mean
this time i don't have nothing to go
back to
are you afraid that maybe you you'll be
here for the rest of your life
yeah i still have hope that eventually
i'll get out of it you know
but it's like even as much as like you
learn to hate
like on a level i never
hate it you know like i believe in god
but um as much as you hate these [ __ ]
people that you see every day
it's crazy it's like
they become like your family you start
liking them
i used to look at them like
you need to have dumpsters or people
give you free food and then you're
sitting along with them you are there
do you feel like you have any friends
real friends
no not real friends i won
one um
there's a guy it was a trick at first
but he like turned into like you know
i stayed with him he gave me the keys on
and off for like that like a year
and then uh
he he would like let me shower there but
we weren't really you know what i mean
but he's clean so he'll always be like
go to rehab go to rehab what are you
going to rehab
every time he sees me thank you
that's all he says now go down here go
to rehab
so sex work is something you've had to
resort to sometimes
and
like i i
don't like it at all you know what i
mean i don't like some girls like they
make you know that's a good money they
do it all day every day
i i don't
i don't do that like i resort to it if i
had to you know i tried to make it a
full-time job
and after like you know being locked in
a couple of bandos because you don't
think about not being able to jump out
abandoned windows then windows are
[ __ ] locked
like that happen once i get scared i
don't do it again for a while and
another girl was held by knife point for
three hours and then you meet her you
know
so i can stick for three hours and she's
telling me a story and she's crying
and she's like yeah you want to go walk
up and down wherever they you know walk
up and i don't do that like people will
proposition me if i'm like sitting on
the corner or something and if i need
money i would do it or whatever but i
learned a steel meal so i don't have to
depend on somebody degrading me anymore
but um
like they like people go through that
[ __ ] and they're ready to go right back
out i i'm not i go through and i get i
get scared you know
i don't do it for a little while
what emotions do you go through
living here
emotions you're depressed i think
there's only really like two
either like you're having a good day so
you're happy or
you're pissed off because somebody just
[ __ ] up something for you whether you
know you were trying to steal out the
store and the security guard caught you
or there's really only two for me up and
down
pissed off or have you
and that happy really is contingent on
how much money is in your pocket
and then that's going fast
and the thing is like
every drug that i knew every drug i've
done my whole life growing up these
ain't the same drugs like i'm not
i smell crack i don't get the high i got
before
so i constantly go to all these
different spots and i'm like they're
selling me fake drugs but if i know
they're fake drugs why the hell am i
still doing them
then the the the dope i
i'm so afraid not to have it
i won't allow myself to go through the
withdrawal
you know what i mean this which is not
like the heroin it was like with heroin
you would
you would um
be hot and cold and your legs your
stomach or whatever you would have like
little symptoms there was a way there
was like steps to it this [ __ ] it's like
you're fine and you're thinking hard i
don't need it i this one bag i did must
have lasted this long and then out of
nowhere you're [ __ ] and throwing off
if you let yourself go so long it's
three days and you're doing dope and
it's not getting you better
so you don't know is it food poisoning
is a stomach virus or is this dope sick
so i just keep doing the damn dope to
just not get to for that to happen again
what does your typical day look like you
wake up in the morning i wake up at
eight like seven or eight well that's
what times the stores will start opening
so if i wake up i either slept on the
night owl which is an all-night bus that
goes from frankfort to upper derby you
get off at frankfurt even though it's
the same bus driver they make you get
off here
and then they pull over here and you got
to jump back on over here and they'll
let you on for free sometimes you're
just on the bus because it's safer than
being on the street
yeah it's warmer
you know in the wintertime and um
so you wake up well you get on the l
they'll start like five or six
and then you know you start your day
what store you want to go to so i go to
the store and i go to you know like a
beer store around here around people
hang out put all my items on the table
they'll buy them up but if they don't
buy them up now you got to walk to every
single store and see if the people want
to buy it you could have 50 60 items and
they're giving you two dollars four
dollars five dollars they ain't giving
you you know because they know you're a
junkie you're going to accept it if you
accept it
and then um
you make your money there
you go get your little bit of drugs
you'd be able to relax for a minute then
you're gonna go back out again
and i enjoy it about four times a day
and then you know i might not have to do
it if you know you get enough samples
that you know you can can make you till
the next night you don't got to go back
out but that's not an everyday thing i
mean samples everyday thing but getting
all six of them you know what i mean
it's not an everyday thing so that's
where like say you went out twice you're
tired of going out that's where a trick
come and offer you something then that's
might be when you take it and it's a
place to stay
and it'll get you high on top of the
money he's putting in your pocket then
and you're tired so that's when that
[ __ ] starts looking good
what would constitute a really good day
for you
what is it what does a good day look
like a good day would look like um
well i go boosting so i get the money
from that then i get my suboxones
so i'll have that as you know i can sell
them
and if i have my food stamps if i have
all three on the same day that that
would be a good day no matter how much
money you have you're still broke the
next day you have a prescription for
suboxone but you sell them yeah rather
than use them yourself yeah
they're probably gonna kick me off this
time because it's been like a year and i
never once had them in my system
yet what are you afraid of at this point
in your life
um
just never just being doing this forever
and turning like i don't know if you've
seen the swords on people the big holes
that the track is causing
my things are still right now it's been
two and a half years i didn't think i
was going to get them but they're
starting on my neck because that's where
i put the needle at
and i don't like these people have holes
that's that's a fear
like i can't believe like i'm wearing
these shoes
i only these shoes were at someone's
house i put them on because my other
shoes were dirty but because you have to
look clean when you go into the store so
they don't watch you you know what i
mean but i would never when i know not
branding sneakers
my front tooth is chipped
the [ __ ] back ones are just like they
just crumble and fall out
like i would never let the [ __ ] go this
long i i hid in the house both times i
was pregnant you know what i mean like i
was really shallow and came to
you know i didn't i did my makeup like
white i wasn't like a hardcore dressed
in the nines but
i would never
look like this and be okay with it and
right now this is a good day for clothes
did you ever dream as a young girl that
this would be where you'd end up
no what did you want to do when you were
young
i think i wanted to be a lawyer when i
was young because my mom worked for
lawyer my aunt worked for lawyers so i
wanted to you know i used to hear about
them talk about their parties or the
houses how they used to have their
houses their living room done every year
and how much money like i want to be
rich
it was okay
um
but like when i had my kids and i had
that i had a house in florida and ground
pool
cars you know i mean the fiancee
i was happy down there i didn't do new
drugs i was like really really into my
kids there
and i was i was [ __ ] happy
but i didn't know i was happy until you
look back now and see like
you're happy then you know
what do you what do you feel
set you on this path more than anything
was it
just your parents not being in your life
nah
because i still you know what i mean you
don't you don't know what it's like now
just have like family you know what i
mean like my family was normal to me
um
like i still loved my life and all you
know like i just looked at it as
somebody told me once when i was younger
like my real mom's body was just a
traveling vessel for me to get to my mom
who raised me
i think like when she died but she was
she had unconditional love
no matter how [ __ ] up you were
you weren't homeless you know what i
mean
she loved you no matter what you did
so that kind of hurt me when when she
died maybe i don't know
but i got out of jail this last time and
i went to recovery house and i was clean
and i got involved with this guy
i knew from the christian recovery house
i never knew like his lifestyle outside
of it he was like a meth head and a
biker and all
and i know nothing about that [ __ ] at
all i just knew like my uncles i
remember when i was younger they would
do weird [ __ ] and i found out older when
i did drugs like why would they paint
that one side of every door every other
door the paint on the inside paint on
the answer and my aunt was like oh
that's when they were doing message but
i remember being little and thinking
they're weird you know what i mean so
when i found out like that was meth i
said i didn't i thought meth meth was
for older people and they just turned
weird i never really messed with this
[ __ ]
and i did that and that if you're
feeling or whatever
i got and plus like just getting with
this dude it was like a double whammy
[ __ ]
high on both of them
and then he turned into like a monster
man like a [ __ ] month attorney he
[ __ ] up my head i think that he gave
me a hot channel purpose i think he
fried me on purpose
and um
i lost my mind and that's how i got back
down here
and um it was the only place i knew
where like if you were homeless you
could sleep on the street and cops
weren't gonna [ __ ] with you you know
and um i actually went back to an ex
and uh because of how [ __ ] up i was in
my head i thought he was on my phone and
he was doing this and he was doing that
he kicked me out and that's really how i
end up down here at the end of the pua
money
that money was kind of bad for me
and i came back down here and
i'm still
here is this your lowest point
yeah right now
the needle park where i found you
is something that's hard to believe just
how many people are
just
injecting in broad daylight not worried
about cops not worried about anything
yeah no
it is it's it's nothing but drug addicts
i know i was saying park bucks county or
that uber driver drove me down
and he's like oh wow this is just open
drug drug market or drug air open air or
something and i don't know what the [ __ ]
i didn't know what it meant
he's like well the girl's shooting
needles in her legs there he was a cop
from new jersey or something and you
know he did this part-time or something
that uber he said he never seen people
do it so out in the open
i just thought every bad neighborhood
major city that was like that
you know like when you're young you come
down here it's fun you know you drive
you're like joyride you come down here
you get whatever your weed or your
zandi's but it used to be different than
you would drive your car down and like
15 different people would come to the to
the car and they all put their hands in
their car and be like
dope hard coke you know and like if
there was dust you would smell you they
all it was like a farm
you know and then i got to a couple
years later park the car and walk up to
the corner
and then i don't remember it ever being
like like this where they have like
whole cities of tents just on the
regular street you know
but
that's how it is i mean they have
programs they're giving the drug addicts
free appointments to get them off the
street but there's not enough programs
there are enough appointments we're
probably not enough funding to pay for
drug addicts at free appointments you
know
what's your biggest regret
biggest regret is
um not the day that when my kids got
placed on my aunt
not getting it together and getting back
there
because i told him i'll be back
we were getting i was getting 26 000 in
a couple of days
i was going back to florida i knew i was
in trouble i knew i was getting too
[ __ ] up
and uh cys came
and place it on my aunt and i had three
weeks so the morning was coming
and um my plan was to like you know go
to get everything set up she was going
to hand the kids back you know get cys
out of it
and then cys well anyway so i told the
kids going to uncle chris is in delaware
you know i'll be back for you i never
ever broke a promise never once even on
drugs i wouldn't make the promise
and that was the one thing i [ __ ]
broke
the most important one
i never understood how my mom left and
never [ __ ] turned around for
me or my sister we never i never
understood it and i [ __ ] did the same
thing she did
and that's the thing i can never get out
chris what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
the most important lesson
i wish i would have just [ __ ] enjoyed
and took things slower when i had my
kids
and another lesson i'm learning now like
i didn't realize how many
like you can't trust there's so much bad
and evil
that's important i really always trust
that people
i learned you can't really trust anybody
nobody
and i keep trying over and over and they
always keep proving me wrong
all right crystal thank you so much for
sharing your story thanks i wish you the
best of luck i hope you figure out a way
i will to get clean
thanks thank you very much
you